- That's an amazing dog.
Beautiful.
What a dog.
I don't even like dogs.
I only like humans.
I don't give a shit about trees,
motherfuckin' nature, animals.
I'm all about the people.
I know that bothers a lot of people but
it bothers me when so many
people don't like people.
Like, everybody always gets so mad at me.
"Oh, you don't like
dogs? You're a bad guy."
"You don't care about Mother Nature?
"You're a bad guy."
Most of you don't like other people.
You're a bad guy.
(hip-hop music)
♫ I know when that hot line blings
♫ That can only mean one thing ♫
- Sir?
- Sir, how are you?
- So sorry, guys.
- No, no no.
You had a good weekend?
- Yeah, very good.
Let's do it.
I hate being late.
- I don't want you going in there--
- You don't want me
going in spitting fire?
How you guys doing?
- We're pretty good.
So, let's--
- If we're gonna go--
It's my legacy.
You know, I never saw this coming.
I love it.
I'm taken aback by it.
Every day now, in my life,
I get an email that's quite powerful,
whether it's somebody
trying to survive cancer
and watching my show,
or somebody starting a career.
Literally, literally no joke.
No hyperbole.
Walking out of my building today,
my doorman stops me.
"Hey, Mr. V?"
You know, it's all very
professional on the Upper East Side.
"Can I show you something?"
He showed me a quote that I said.
The quote kind of went like,
the guy or gal that grows up cooking
with their grandmother in the kitchen
is always going to beat the person that
goes to culinary school.
It was kind of the essence of doing it.
He said that this quote
inspired his friend
and changed that person's life and
is now at, ironically, at one
of the great culinary schools
and has a profession.
That's kind of funny.
But, you know, it's just crazy.
I mean, I wish it on all of you.
I wish it on all of you to know that,
even though you're going
after your own self-interests,
by proxy, by sawdust, by process,
you're bringing so much good to the world.
It's an incredibly intoxicating feeling.
I push against it.
I don't wanna be Tony Robbins and
I don't wanna be Oprah.
I don't.
It's right there for me.
I know I've got it but
I want to prove that
I'm a real businessman and
all these different things.
But, as I'm getting older,
you know, it's interesting,
literally the thing
that happened at forty--
it's kind of, here's a callback--
the only thing that happened is
am I being selfish to be
able to prove to everybody
that I'm able to build
$100 million businesses
because I want to be a businessman
and that I'm holding off
this inspirational thing
that I've got? And, should I go
all 100% into inspiration because
I'll be successful and
I'll impact more people?
It's been an intense feeling.
It's definitely the
thing that I'll spend my
seventies, eighties and
hundreds on pondering
did I play this unbelievably
raw gift properly?
Did I find the right
balance of checking the box
of practicality and not guru for me,
because I needed that for
me while still helping
enough people along the way?
It's very interesting how
I feel about this gift
and it's a gift through communication and
it's a gift through circumstance and
it's a gift through being
perfectly parented and
it's a gift through the
talents that I have but
whatever I was given, I was given it.
The reason I'm reading this audiobook is
because I know that I
have a responsibility
to read it because Johnny
Thompson reading this
is not going to have the same impact as
the four days I allocated to this and
that will bring value to so many of you
and will inspire so many
of you to do something.
Something great.
Something good.
Something just a little bit
better than you would have had
if we didn't cross paths.
Yeah.
- That's actually one of
the most interesting audios
I have ever done.
- Really?
- Seriously.
- Thank you, man.
That means a lot to me.
- Because it's actually somewhere between
a podcast--
- Yes.
- A meta-audiobook.
It's very unusual and I think
it's going to be terrific.
It really will.
- Thank you so much.
- It's going to be really interesting
for people to listen to.
- Thank you so much.
- Not the same old, same old.
For sure.
- Definitely different.
- And in a good way.
- Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
You guys are super.
I mean, four days.
That's a lot of time in my world.
Like, the way I roll.
You guys helped me so much.
You really did.
And really, Day One was
especially challenging.
- Sure.
- And I really appreciate you guys.
Thank you.
- [Woman] Did you go
to the game last night?
- I did.
The Knick game?
- [Woman] How do you feel?
- Feel sad.
- Nice to meet you.
How you doing, man?
- Eric. Nice to meet you.
It's a pleasure, man.
- Gary.
- Hey. Preston. Nice to meet you.
- Preston. Eric and Preston.
Nice to meet you guys.
- Hey, how you doing?
Justin. Nice to meet you.
- Gary.
No, you want to go around?
Jerry? Gary.
- Jamel.
- Jamel. Nice to meet you, man.
Let's go.
- Hello.
- So excited to meet you.
- I'm Kenny.
- Kenny?
- Nice to meet you, Gary.
- Have we met before?
- Nope.
- Such a familiar face.
- Gary? Harry.
- Harry?
- Harry.
- Nice to meet you.
I have one already.
It shouldn't kind of feel like the--
are we going to be okay?
Big equipment.
Thanks, bro.
I like yours, too.
How are you guys doing?
All good?
- Good, good.
- Let me see what can happen.
- Right.
Like if we can even get the
beginnings of it, something.
Really we don't want to know any secrets.
We just want to know like--
- I know.
- We'll just go with the flow
for the first couple hours
and then we'll check back in.
- Regroup.
- Regroup, yeah.
I like that.
- Hi, Gary. I'm John.
- John?
Nice to meet you. Gary.
How are you?
- Good, you?
- Really well.
It was a lot of fun.
We're not really, like that's literally
only the second time.
Did you buy that in Jack Threads?
- Yeah.
We're gonna like change wardrobes.
- We're gonna all go around the corner
and then, you're, my dear, are gonna have to stop.
- Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is episode 178 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
It's been an exciting day here at Vayner.
DRock, you can show it,
we'll give 'em a little
look at what's going on. DRock,
these are big cameras DRock.
I mean you're holding a very
small camera. Is this make
you feel insecure? these
are big ass cameras, DRock.
You okay?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Thank you
guys, you were great,
that was really entertaining.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
Thanks guys, I'll see ya tomorrow.
- [Voiceover] No, talk
tonight, then see you tomorrow.
- Talk to you tonight, see you tomorrow.
So I'm really glad you
guys are here together,
I'm really excited about this, like,
I feel like there's been a
lot of momentum in general.
I'm really excited, I'm
really pumped about DailyVee,
I'm super pumped about
where we are pre sales on
both deals, I feel like my
brand through our exercises
has created a opportunity
for us to get 4,000 book buys
whereas with Jab Jab,
1,500 felt a lot to people.
You know, so my brand
is in a better place,
but I'm really wanting tonight,
and I got to speak to Andy
and Alex over the weekend
a little bit so I'm gonna
rely on them to rekindle
stuff, 'cause I'm pretty fried,
last night I had dinner
with the Warriors team
after the game.
The whole team.
Guys the audio book is fire,
guys the audio book is fire.
The audio book is fuckin' fuckin' fire.
- In Crush It! you said it,
like go to my Facebook page
and tell me what you thought of the story.
- [Gary] Yeah I kind of did
that at the end a little bit.
Little different. Done.
- [Voiceover] The fact that
you re-answered questions.
- Dude I answered completely differently,
like the audio book has
nothing to do with the book.
They're literally two different things.
- Seriously?
- Yeah, but I'd like to
think, off script I fuckin',
I did a new book.
Yeah, because I don't like reading,
so I realized wait a minute,
let me just answer it,
they're all gonna be the same,
or they're the most updated
thoughts, or they complement.
I think the game--
- [Man] When'd you make that change?
- I made that change pretty quickly.
- [Voiceover] 'Cause it's really funny
watching you read and then
switching from reading
to just audio book.
- [Gary] It's so different right?
- [Voiceover] It's so warm right now.
- I hate reading, I'm so bad at it. What?
- Ease down, proper reading.
- Yeah, you know what's funny?
I was definitely better
at reading than I thought.
Actually, you're gonna be blown away
by what I'm about to tell you.
I kinda learned how to read a little bit.
I'm not kidding, you know what I did?
(calm music)
Oh you can, just don't
hold down the button,
you just press it, cool.
All right.
All right Book Squad, here's all the peeps
that you interact with, DRock's
getting some advice for food.
Mike's not letting me eat, there's Andy.
Anyway, ladies, I need to
switch this, double-tap?
No, fuck it, all right,
guys I need your help,
I'm super concerned
about local bookstores.
Because of my tour, every
other time has been a Powell's,
an Elliott Bay and Changing Hands,
in the first week I went
to the key book stores,
team, we need to figure out, Andy, Alex,
we need to speak to Harper
Collins about the 25, 50
key book stores, and
then I'm going to need
you guys to help me organize around
buying books from those stores,
whether you do it, or
you get people to do it,
that's what the squad's for, I need it.
So, these 30 to 50 book
stores really matter to me.
In this comment section,
can you start talking about
your local book store, and
can you tomorrow call them
and ask how many books are on order?
My prediction is zero to two,
that's how local book stores
do it, I need 25 to 50 to
100 per these 50 book stores,
so let's start rallying the
community, want you to knock on doors,
jack cars and drive
people to the book store
make them buy the books.
I really wanna focus on that,
so I need your help on that.
Why don't you guys start
brainstorming in the comments?
- Yeah, Facebook that,
that's the one thing
I thought of that I didn't think of.
I saw you sending out a Tweet that you
sent to Alex?
My understanding is within
the first 10 minutes
Facebook's deciding what's going on
and people know that it's
a 30 minute, 20 minute show
and they just.
- The Monday morning
video this morning got
108,000 organic views.
- [Man] On a reshare.
If we would've uploaded immediately,
it would've gotten 400,000.
- Entrepreneur Answered is killing
on Facebook as a YouTube link.
[Man] Yep.
- Should we just do more of them?
- [Men] Yep.
- Cheers guys to good health.
To good health, DRock get in here,
put the camera down.
- Super intriguing day
for #AskGaryVee 12,
it was very meta, DRock and I,
DailyVee, thank you
keep it don't edit it.
Little fried got home super
late, got up super early,
and tomorrow, 5:45 for basketball,
CNBC following me around.
Gonna be part of a new show.
I get one of the episodes,
so DRock is limited
by what he could pick up today.
A very big ass GaryVee book day.
Finished up the recording, seems
like there was a lot of hype
for the audio book.
Glad that's done, that was woof.
Very excited about the
meeting we just had,
lot of strategies, a lot of
thoughts, a lot of contemplating,
a lot of debating, a lot
of putting pieces in place
for next 36 days before
the book comes out.
Just a really really good day.
Got a lot of client stuff done,
good to see Draeman.
All star, beast.
Just a grinder, you know,
not the longest day for me,
six to 10:30. Not the longest day for me
but tough. I didn't get as
much sleep as I wanted,
looking forward to getting
some sleep tonight.
It's already 10:30. Gotta be up
at 5:30, gotta hang with Lizzie
a little bit here, catch up on the email.
We're in grind mode right now.
We're grindin'.
(upbeat pop music)